my little test is you know the more
people that have to be involved in the
conspiracy the less likely the theory is
true the more components that have to
come together just at the right time in
the right place again it's probably not
likely if it if if a lot of things have
to happen because again chance chaos uh
contingency accidents you know people
just don't do what they're supposed to
do you know I remember that when my
first book came out I went on G Gordon
litty's Radio Show in Washington DC
white people believe we're things so and
I discussed conspiracies a little bit in
there and he asked me about it and I
said well you're the expert you're Mr
Watergate and he says well actually most
conspiracies are a bunch of baloney
conspiracy theories are because people
can't keep their mouth shut and most
people are incompetent
foreign
social media or how do you think social
media plays a part in all of this you
know one of the things just in terms of
the way the internet's structured that I
always think about is I remember the
internet when it started or you know
started on basic AOL or prodigy or
something you go to a website you get to
the bottom of the page and that was it
meaning you could scroll for a certain
period of time then it would stop then
we got infinite scroll so more and more
and more kept coming if you're on
Twitter you can go more and more and
more that Rabbit Hole uh is endless now
and I think a lot of that probably also
feeds a certain part of the brain that
would lead people to some of these ideas
yeah it does uh I mean the history of
conspiracism there's always been
conspiracy theories nothing new there
but but the spread of them in real time
and the depth that people could go that
I talked about in the book of the JFK
conspiracy theorist you know back in the
60s and 70s they're just meeting in
little hotel conference rooms with two
dozen people and they have their little
mimeograph newsletters that they mail
out and so not very many people you know
new about this or we're in into it now
you can reach you know millions of
people
instantly in real time and so the spread
is more rapid the the you know kind of
going down the rabbit hole the siloing
off of people into these
um uh communities that it's hard to
penetrate
um you know that's that's the harder
part is it do you think also easier to
debunk some of these things because of
the speed of information just as fast as
it can spread it can also be debunked
that much more quickly yeah to me that's
the only solution is that because I'm
not in favor of censorship or kicking
people off of social media because they
said the wrong thing this doesn't help
for two reasons one you might be wrong
and that guy that you just kicked off
you might be right no one's omniscient
how do you know you know uh Jon Stewart
Mill you know is it's like if he who
knows only in his own position doesn't
even know that so it's good to listen to
these other people uh but and then
second if you kick somebody off you
cancel culture and so on then Outsiders
observing this will go I wonder if that
guy has something to say and because
they're making such a big deal about it
right banned in Boston oh I want to read
those banned books right
and so you know when someone like Joe
Rogan has on Robert Malone to talk about
vaccines and and cardio issues you know
everybody made a big stink about that
it's like well first of all Joe's not 60
minutes where he has to have you know
guests on each side or whatever it's not
what he does you know that going in and
so but if you make a big deal about it
now everyone wants to know well who is
this Robert Malone guy and what is his
argument because no one seems to debunk
it they just say oh it was bad he had
him on well okay what is the problem
somebody should say here's the argument
here's the response and what's what's so
interesting about that is if you
remember so he has Dr Malone on who had
I think if I'm not mistaken more patents
on mRNA technology than anybody I mean
it's not like this guy's a kook right so
he has him on the media goes crazy about
it because he's talking about Ivermectin
and all of these things and then you're
you remember what happened about four
days later where suddenly we had a week
of Joe Rogan saying the n-word and
should Joe Rogan be de-platformed off
Spotify and everywhere else and that I
think led to LED people to believe you
know I don't even know that this is a
conspiracy theory but that there was
some sort of coordinated attack by the
corporate press on Rogan like he was
becoming too influential so it behooved
CNN to push these oh Joe Rogan's a
racist stories because he's moving in on
their territory I don't know if that's a
conspiracy I mean I don't have all I
don't have the documents from Zucker CNN
but it feels like something that's kind
of there I suspect that's not a top-down
conspiracy like we think of a conspiracy
theory of you know the Illuminati or
somebody power cigarette smoking people
behind closed doors are calling the
shots and the reason I'm skeptical of
most of those theories is because the
world is too complex there's too much
Randomness there's too much chaos from
the bottom up and no one can control it
no one's in control this is part of my
my theory is that it's one thing to be a
a little afraid or anxious about there's
some cabal going on of 12 people called
the Illuminati running the world and
doing a crappy job of it but it's quite
another to think actually nobody's in
control
right there no one can explain the
economy why Wars I mean I don't think
Putin even knows if he's going to use
tactical nukes or not let alone Biden or
defense department or I don't think
anybody knows it's just impossible to
know so I view that as is that scarier
or more comforting if nobody's in
control I like it because I'm kind of
libertarian in my personal attitudes and
I it's okay with me but people that
prefer a structured hierarchical
worldview that's predictable that
they're not and they tend to be more
conspiratorial in their thinking a
little more paranoid a little more
suspicious that there's things going on
and again things do go on so how do you
know well my little test is you know the
more people that have to be involved in
the conspiracy the less likely the
theory is true the more components that
have to come together just at the right
time in the right place again it's
probably not likely if it if if a lot of
things have to happen because again
chance chaos uh contingency accidents
you know people just don't do what
they're supposed to do you know I
remember that when my first book came
out I went on G Gordon litty's Radio
Show in Washington DC the white people
believe we're things so and I discussed
conspiracies a little bit in there and
he asked me about it and I said well
you're the expert you're Mr Watergate
and he says well actually most
conspiracies are a bunch of baloney
conspiracy theories are because people
can't keep their mouth shut and most
people are incompetent and you know so
this is like 9 11 truth you know the
Bush Administration was in on 911 let it
happen on purpose lie up or made it
happen on purpose Maya well in fact
negative evidence Wikileaks you know
millions of classified documents not one
not one document about 9 11 or we know
they're coming or we're going to let it
happen or you know planting explosive
nothing right so that tells me if if it
was an inside job and these were
classified documents we would predict
that there should be some leakage there
there isn't because most conspiracies we
do find out about them right Lincoln was
assassinated by conspiracy we knew
within hours who did it same thing with
Kennedy I mean Oswald was discovered
within an hour we they had him at that
theater and so we find out about these
things but not one person wants to go on
record about you know the fake moon
landing where 911 is an inside job or
not one so that's very probably not true
what would you say about something like
the the hunter Biden laptop story where
you know New York Post which is
generally thought of as a reputable news
organization they say this is true they
you know they have their sources Etc big
Tech Twitter particularly comes in you
can't share these stories you can't even
share them through your own private
messaging your own direct messaging on
our platform then other platforms start
doing it as well of course it all turns
out to be legit and there's a lot of
pretty pretty bad stuff on there some
nasty stuff on there
um I think a lot of people see that as
they see that as a coordinated
conspiracy that that in essence that
thing was going to be damaging to Joe
Biden they wanted Joe Biden to be
president they wanted to be rid of Trump
we accept that big Tech can just get in
on this like does that is that a
conspiracy or is that yeah that's an
interesting example because here it
would be a conspiracy in the traditional
sense if say the news networks called
each other and said you know I'm I'm not
going to run the story are you going to
run the story I I won't run it if you
won't run it if that was shown that
would be a more traditional definition
of a conspiracy more likely is is more
of kind of a cultural shift or Trend
we're all liberals we want to protect
our guy and so we're just going to bury
the story you know I'm gonna do it and
you're going to do it we it's kind of
common knowledge I don't have to call
you up you just know that you know we're
going to kind of work together to
support our guy or criticize the other
guy that's more normal that happens I
think a lot uh without the concerted
top-down you know private phone calls
kind of messaging to coordinate the
effort that would be my suspicion for
that for that that one if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about Academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our Academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell